so 47 is silver silver is one of the
elements which is found in nature
actually as the elements if you're lucky
wandering around you can find the length
of silver in the ground not many people
do
and silver has been therefore known
since really ancient times it is another
element which has in relatively modern
times become importance it was used as
they are still used as the basis for
photographic film the black you can see
here in the film is silver and the
photographic film works with a
remarkable reaction of silver chloride
or bromide which with a very small
amount of light can initiate a reaction
which then when you put it in a tube tap
of developer will spread so that a small
amount of light can produce a large
amount of black on a material very
recently people have become excited
about silver because it has
antimicrobial properties it will kill
microbes as many people know that make
bacteria are becoming resistant to many
of the medicines that we use to kill
them but remarkably up till now that
they do not seem to be able to resist
silver perhaps because silver attacks
several different mechanisms in the
bacterium at the same time so there is a
lot of work going on including some at
this university for putting small
amounts of silver into implants there
all tubes that may be stuck into the
body to prevent bacteria from causing
infections
there are even suggestions that the
paint on doors in hospitals should
contain silver to prevent bacterial
infection being spread from one person
to another a bacteria also cause your
feet to smell and you can if you want by
through the internet socks with
the nanoparticles in the socks which are
claimed to stop your feet smelling but I
never tried them so you do to your own
risk